[موسيقى]
من الوقوع في دوامه الاجور والاسعار حيث
تؤدي زياده الاجور الى زياده الاسعار
والتي بدورها تؤدي تؤدي الى زيادات في
الاجور
سيناريو يتشابه مع بدايه ازمه التضخم
الحاليه في امريكا برامج دعم مالي ضخمه من
الحكومه لمواجهه تداعيات كورونا
الاقتصاديه احدها قدمت تريليون دولار نقدا
للامريكيين تدفقت الاموال فازداد الطلب
على السلع والخدمات لكن الشركات لم تستطع
مواكبه الطلب لاسباب مختلفه ما بين نقص في
اشباه الموصلات وتوقف حركات الشحن العالمي
النتيجه اذا التضخم امريكي بنسبه 6.4%
نسبه تبدو ضئيله لكن تاثير التضخم على بعض
المنتجات الغذائيه الاساسيه كان هائلا ما
ادى لحدوث زياده سنويه كبيره في تكلفه
الغذاء في المدارس الامريكيه بنسبه تصل
الى
254% مات سعر وجبه الغداء في المدارس
الابتدائيه نحو ثلاثه دولارات اسعار تذاكر
الط يران في مطارات امريكا قفزت بنسبه 36%
امر متوقع بعد ارتفاع تكاليف الوقود الى
جانب نقص العماله وارتفاع الطلب بعد
الخروج من جائحه كورونا اما تذاكر خدمات
النقل العام فارتفعت بنسبه
23.8 في المئه وكل هذا يلمسه الشارع
ساسطون كان هناك وسال